why are you why you don't like so you
know like me coffee it's been a rough
week for Selena Gomez she's not only
under the weather but she also got stung
by a Manowar while vacationing in Hawaii
yeah take a closer look her friend had
to carry her off the beach on New Year's
Day as she tried to keep a smile on her
face look at her now singer ring in the
New Year in the Sunshine State with her
pals and luckily she will be a-okay but
if you're wondering what a Manowar is
well it's similar to a jellyfish they
are known for their bright blue
tentacles and get this Selena isn't
alone they sting hundreds of people a
day around the world
[Music]
hopefully Sal is on the mend though
she's dropping her new album rare on
January 10 and she's been working
through the pain I'm sick and I tried to
redo this video 500 times basically I'm
saying pull it together
she's been signing a whole lot of copies
of the album I just wanted to show you
guys that I'm anybody who ends up
getting these they're signed for me no
one else and I'm about to do it it's
basically growing around up to 25 days I
like to come at things with my best
that's all I know how to do last summer
a source told ET celles new music would
be extremely personal and she's already
proven that like it was easy more than
anything I'm just I think I feel a sense
of relief you know it's been four years
since I've been working on this album
and it's actually perfect timing because
I was gonna release it two years ago and
none of the words that I'm speaking
would have existed
[Music]